let me just say we're not going to show
Roger
Waters video it's just it's too long I
do encourage people to go look at it
anyway it takes the form of a an open
letter which he
reads and he describes his uh desire for
what he thinks should happen in the
Middle East which I regard as perfectly
Preposterous um and then he you find
perfectly Preposterous what he describes
as what should happen yes he basically
is calling for a ceasefire at a moment
when um you know you have more than a
thousand Israeli citizens dead under the
most barbaric intentionally barbaric
circumstances conceivable and I don't
know how many hostages there are but a
huge number of people imperiled in what
we know are terrible circumstan ances
and are probably worse than we can
imagine but you know ceasefire is just
an incoherent idea at this
moment that said um I want to explore a
little bit the status of Roger Waters I
have
um said some things about the man and I
want people to understand all of the
related and uh implied connections can I
just uh I honestly have no idea to what
degree our audience may not be familiar
with what a Roger Waters is I I have no
idea so um just say he was um one of the
by by some estimations um the lead
creative uh Talent uh in Pink Floyd um
at least after Sid Barrett was no longer
part of it uh and um you know Pink Pink
Floyd the band uh of course
was an
extraordinarily uh insightful and
unusual band in an era in the late 60s
'70s through they put out their final
album The Final Cut in 1983 um in an era
of unusually uh insightful bands but
they were you know they were unique
among uh among unique entities they were
let me let me just say um they they
happened to be um you know one of the
only bands that I actually listened to
ever in high school because of my
upbringing mostly with classical music
and then I found them and went these
people speak to me in a way that um and
it was mostly I was listening to music
that had been put out well before you
know my time um not while before my time
but many years to a couple decades
um enough so that actually one of the
very few concerts I actually went to um
literally the night before I started
college I drove several hours to see
Roger Waters live in concert um so this
you know this this is a music and
musician and an U that has been
extraordinarily meaningful yes and I
would say also deeply meaningful to me
and I would say unambiguously meaningful
to us you and I bonded over a shared
appreciation for this uh when we met in
high school yeah so and I would just
change one thing about what you
presented about the history I really
think you need to think about Pink Floyd
as two bands there's the Sid Barrett
band and then there's what happened when
Sid Barrett effectively lost his mind
left the band and then there's the uh
Roger Waters and Gilmore band that
followed yeah
um and you know most of the albums that
people know the wall the Dark Side of
the Moon are in that second version of
Pink Floyd Wishy were here yeah wish you
were here right animals yeah wish you
were here which is actually
um written it is about Sid Barrett I
believe the idea is it is it is Roger
wat's lament that his friend Sid Barrett
is not present yeah I think it may
but any anyway
um so Roger Waters has a kind of complex
status in my mind and I wanted to
explore this because I think especially
this week we are seeing first of all I
mean if there's there's so much evil
that has been uh we are forced to
Grapple with in light of the attack by
Hamas on
Israel um that there's you know there's
no shortage of terrible outgrowths of
these events if there's one positive
thing in my opinion it is that the
anti-Semitism that some of us have been
seeing and trying to call attention to
is no longer a rumor now everybody has
seen it it has been uh you know the
celebrations in uh the street across the
world tell you these are not people
simply
celebrating uh a surprise attack these
are people who know what happened in
that attack and are not embarrassed by
it they are not troubled by it and that
is
so um the implications of it could
hardly be more profound these are people
who have zero empathy for the victims
there even though the victims were
innocent these were not this is not the
Israeli government about which we could
talk about what role they did or didn't
play in setting the stage for this but
literally innocent people including
children and no empathy for them
whatsoever so the anti-Semitism that
many of us have been seeing and trying
to raise the alarm about is now visible
to many people who couldn't see it
before and that is
um a tiny positive thing compared to the
horror that we've seen but it is
important because it's going to play a
role going forward it it it is important
and I've I've heard individually uh from
people who um are extraordinarily
sympathetic um um to to Israel uh who
are saying now I've been hearing Brett
talk about him seeing arise in
anti-Semitism and I haven't seen it and
I didn't disbelieve that he was seeing
it right um you know these I'm not
talking about you know haters or
disbeliever I'm just talking about
people who are saying I hadn't seen it I
didn't know what he was seeing uh it was
cryptic and now it's not cryptic yeah
and people are reporting not just what
we are seeing in public but just at the
individual level
of people who others thought were
friends aren't reaching out to ask is
your family okay right um it there it's
like the veil has fallen and it has one
one friend of mine from Portland uh said
um it feels a little bit like what it
felt like in Portland in mid
2021 when everyone had gotten be so many
people had gotten behind the everyone
must get vaccinated or else they're evil
people and uh this
is more terrifying yet and more hangous
it is and I hope um two things have
happened one people who um
have no anti-Semitism to them at all
couldn't see it and didn't know what to
make of it and this week they are seeing
it and it is causing them to think a new
right which is good but there's another
thing that I hope will happen which I
haven't seen yet but my guess is if I
under if I read the landscape correctly
this is almost certain to happen at
least in enough cases to matter there
are people good people who have been
traversing the edges of this
anti-semitic landscape they have been
trying to understand what to think about
the presence of Jews in organizations
that they see as hostile to humanity in
karma in government people Bing right
and they're trying to understand what to
do with it and they're getting they are
trafficking in these sort of shallow end
of the pool anti-semitic tropes they are
trafficking in Collective responsibility
and guilt which is really the sinanan of
anti-Semitism of of all of the
bigotry uh that does population level
broad brush if you're a member of EX you
must be be because X has done bad things
if you are a member of X you are a bad
thing yourself instead of recognizing
that there are bad Jews of which there
are many MH saying the Jews that's the
place where you cross the line and the
point is and we will get back to the
lineage level thing which takes Jews out
of this entirely and just says actually
this is an evolutionary question that
applies to an old style of interaction
that all of us come from all of our
ancestors did this but anyway we'll come
back to that in a second what I'm hoping
is that some of the good people who have
been experimenting at The Fringe of this
very bad style of thought this very
dangerous style of thought will actually
be made aware of what slippery slope
they are standing on the edge of and
they will say
oh I don't want to be there that's not
me that's a violation of my own values
and they will step back from that slip
slippery SLP I really hope that happens
because there are a lot of people that I
do regard as uh fundamentally good who
are experimenting with some
fundamentally bad ideas and it is not
helpful yeah um but back to back to
Roger
Waters um I said a couple weeks ago on
Twitter and I do have a slight regret
about the way I said it I was trying to
defend Roger wat's right to speak he had
been Uninvited to speak I think at the
University of
Pennsylvania um and I because he had
been playing with Nazi tropes yeah but
that's actually a bad but but that isn't
that that was the stated reason I think
so we haven't said that yet I think the
stated reason was
anti-Semitism the claims about his
playing with Nazi tropes are absurd okay
he's not playing with Nazi trops this is
somebody who is resolutely anti-nazi and
at a at a familial level right this is a
person his father died fighting the
Nazis right his father died fighting the
Nazis and he has been anti-nazi and he
has been portraying Nazis as the evil
sons of that they were in his
art for his entire history so that's a
bad rrap okay I don't think that that is
that his you know putting on Nazi
costumes and shooting at the audience is
about him harboring Nazi sympathy that's
really really wrong but I do think and I
said in defending his right to speak
what I what I said was that back when I
was at Penn Lewis farakhan had come to
speak and we all knew he was an
anti-semite and we went anyway and I'm
glad I did and I don't want to see Roger
Waters shut down because of
anti-Semitism I think he should be
allowed to speak and people should go
listen yeah so I understood myself to be
defending him but I did acknowledge that
I believed after all of the evidence
that I had seen that in fact he did
Harbor anti-Semitism but I want to be
really clear about what that does and
does not mean to me because I have a
feeling that when people hear a Jewish
person say that somebody is an
anti-semite it implies things to them
that are not at least inherently true so
you have heard you the audience have now
heard Heather and me talk about the fact
that Roger Waters and Pink Floyd have a
special importance to it us and unlike
some of the stuff that I listened to
back then I actually still find that
importance many of it many of those
things you age out of them being useful
they're just not insightful anymore when
you become older and wiser Pink Floyd
there's still a lot of value it actually
stands up really well and I go back and
I listen to that stuff with regularity
because it is Meaningful so what does
that mean that I'm saying that this
person who is responsible for things
that I hold dear I believe Harbor's
anti-Semitism even though I'm a Jew and
that's means that I believe he has some
bias against people like me some uh
unreasoned bias some emotional bias that
is not founded on
facts
well let me just lay it out a I think
[Music]
um we have not done a good job we
civilization have not done a good job
figuring out what we think about the
difference between binary categories and
Spectra right the fact that sex is being
claimed to be a spectrum and that that's
obviously tactical and sex isn't a
spectrum so we see the claim that
something as a is a spectrum as sort of
inherently suspect because we know that
we can be tricked by people you know
parading
Spectra well anti-Semitism is an actual
Spectrum there is rabid anti-semitism
ISM people who just think Jews should be
wiped out and we've seen them uh
chanting and celebrating in streets
across the world um there is an entire
range to a flight suspicions that
certain people Harbor um that uh affect
interactions and I have never thought
that uh that Waters was a rabid
anti-semite in any way I just think he
has a little bit of bias that is you
know no doubt tied up in complex
feelings about the loss of his father
and the nature of World War II and who
knows whatever else um and the friends
he happens to have made um are more
likely to be Palestinians than Israelis
and I I mean I think that ends up
predicting some amount of of this that
if you know if you know someone with a
personal story and they are on this side
rather than that you are more likely to
see that as the enemy who is doing ill
in the
world so for those who would ask why I
think this after looking at lots of
statements of waters looking at his
desire you know in his art he does stuff
he dresses up as a Nazi and he shoots at
the audience um as he is very clearly um
portraying Nazis as villains right so
this is is a guy whose art includes the
portrayal of enemies for the purpose of
the audience drawing the correct
conclusion about them but he also you
know the Flying Pig that flies above his
uh concerts he you know has put Jewish
stars on them they drop money uh you
know he's had phrases put on them that
are anti-semitic now it could be that
this is Roger Waters doing the same
thing he's doing when he uh puts on a
Nazi outfit and attempt to call
attention to anti-Semitism but it
doesn't seem like that and what's more
the thing that really caused me to draw
a conclusion at all
was people he has known well who report
that in their interactions anti-Semitism
is apparent to them including David
Gilmore right so I don't think he's a
rabid
anti-semite and if we can get back to
what he lays out in this um letter of
his this open letter
uh it actually gives us kind of an
insight as to where he is the letter he
is defending he is both putting
proposals on the table which make no
sense in light of where we are but he is
also describing the world that he wishes
to see and I guess I would actually just
ask people who are trying to figure out
what to do with Roger Waters to draw the
following
dichotomy this is not a man with any
demon demonstrated capacity to
understand the the difficulties that
block us from getting from A to
B however this is somebody with a very
highly developed capacity to describe
where it is that we should
goh and so put aside completely I in my
opinion his suggestion of fires his his
his solution making his process oriented
solution making but take very serious
Roger Waters dream and he describes it
as a dream in this piece because Roger
Waters has had interesting dreams uh
over the course of many years and he has
often put them
into his art and those
dreams you know for our audience members
let me just say that I am
somebody who people often tell me that
I'm very
articulate I believe that the reason
that I am articulate if in fact I am has
a lot to do with um word play word play
that came in the form
of uh playful banter at the dinner table
but maybe even more importantly um I pay
very close attention to artfully
constructed lyrics that are meaningful
that convey something important and do
so in a way that lodges them in the mind
specially
and in in any case Waters has outlined
various dreams these are not things that
Roger Waters knows how to accomplish
right they may not even be reasonable
places that could exist but he has
outlined some things in ways that
resonate for those of us who hear them
and in one partic so in the in the
letter here that he he newly provides he
describes in effect a vision of a world
after after these conflicts are uh put
to
rest and that world is what I'm
calling the
West this is a world in which everybody
is equally protected by the structures
and just everybody is equally protected
from the structures and protected in a
way that liberates them do I believe
that if Roger Water
was in a all powerful position to
construct that world would he do it yes
do I believe that he would include Jews
in that world in which everybody was
equally protected I do believe that he
would do that there might be some little
nagging thing that he would feel that
that was injust perhaps but nonetheless
I do think that
he is telling it like it is with respect
to what world he would like to see and
that he is a bit confused about the
world as it is and he is confused about
the rules that would allow us to get
there but um I did want to point out one
particular thing uh from a
uh I think it is from the wall it has to
be from the wall um I wanted to point to
a set of lyrics that I have known since
you and I met that's uh a long time ago
um it is from a song that I think is
called the Gunner's dream the Gunner's
dream is the Final Cut oh it's the Final
Cut yeah all right
um it I know that right away just
because you and I talked about the
Gunner's dream earlier and I and I went
back and listen to it yeah I was I had
the feeling it was on the Final Cut but
then it narratively fits in with many of
the things on the wall which is why I
was confused but the Final Cut collects
many of the things that were cut from
earlier albums I believe oh I don't know
that yeah um but anyway the the Gunner's
dream is obviously a reference to his
father um his father who died in World
War II in Italy um I believe was shot
down
and in the letter that Waters uh
released yesterday um he refers to his
father uh and the death of his father
fighting the Nazis and he refers to his
father's dream which he says he shares
so in the Final Cut boy I'm a little
concerned about singing this for one
thing uh still fighting that cough and
for another thing it always breaks me up
a little bit for reasons that I think
will become obvious yeah um so it starts
out um this is first two yeah yeah um a
place to stay well hold on hold on uh
floating
down through the
clouds my memories come rushing up to
meet me now and in the space between the
heavens and the corner of some foreign
field I had a
dream I had a
dream a place to
stay enough to
eat somewhere old Heroes Shuffle safely
down the street where you can speak out
loud about your doubts and fears and
what's more no one ever disappears
you'll never hear their standard issue
kicking in your door you can relax on
both sides of the tracks and
Maniacs don't blow
holes in bandsmen by remote control and
everyone has recourse to the
law and no one kills the children
anymore so
Roger Waters describes the west and he
does it very
eloquently there are things included in
those few lines that
are beautiful in their compassion the
fact that he carves
out a place for war
heroes in a world without
War
and the idea in in the Same album in
which he puts war criminals in a home
for the Fletcher Memorial Home Britain
curable tyrants and Kings
yep so this is important for a number of
reasons the outline of what the West is
is vital and people are losing track of
it and when I talk about the fact that
lineage versus lineage violence is in a
position to dislodge our understanding
of the West and to replace it because
although the West is better it is safer
it is fairer it is less violent it is
more productive it is more liberating it
is highly desirable for any human being
to join something that is a stable
version of the west but it is fragile it
is easily vetoed by people who have
something else in
mind Waters is laying out picture of the
West and one of the things as I
Revisited these lyrics for the first
time in some time today what I realized
is the
tragedy of how much farther we are from
that description than we were even 25
years ago the idea you and I spend a lot
of time
worrying about what we say and what its
impact on our safety will
be the idea that he
expresses where you can speak out loud
about your doubts and fears we cannot
speak out loud about our doubts and
fears not in safety anyway that is a
tragedy that we have lost that he talks
about everyone has recourse to the law
that is not true anymore that is that is
a reality that we had within our grasp
and it is slipping away because
something else has taken hold and no one
kills the children anymore exactly and
the point is this week you can see the
status of children in this even the
mafia leaves children out
it we are somewhere so desperately
dangerous um
so
um I was going to saying stanza go for
it uh from later in the Same
album which is I think reflective of
what many people are feeling right now
um the ayous track from the album the
final
cut through the fishey lens of tear
stained
eyes I can barely Define the shape of
this moment in
time and far from Flying high in Clear
Blue Sky
I'm spiraling down to the hole in the
ground where I
[Music]
hide this is where so many people are
right
now it does not
provide a solution does not provide a
way
forward that is the stanza of this album
that stuck with me the most from the 80s
when I first heard it
as I understand it was written
autobiographically this is something
that was supposed to be in the wall at
first um and it is written by someone
who is desperate who is dark who is uh
at risk of ending
himself which is never a place that I
was that was never me uh and yet this
always
resonated
how and you know and his poetry as so
much of what Waters rights is I can
barely Define the shape of this moment
in
time this is what we are all trying to
do and we are being told what the shape
of this moment in time is we're being
told that some things are true that
can't be and we are being told that this
is just like what has happened before
and there's nothing new here
no no well let's let's say this I
believe that we can be we thinking
people we people who have not lost our
minds in the last
week can be certain that we are being
had yeah we do not know who we are being
had by right at the very least we can
say that Hamas has engaged in an attack
that it deliberately constructed to
produce an overwhelming response why it
wanted that overwhelming response we
don't know who its Partners were we
don't know but the point is at the very
least we are being had that somebody as
diabolical as that is in the position to
Define what the rest of the world is
allowed to do right that is
[Music]
intolerable